tente ça c'est un grand film c'est un
film qui a une écriture comme on disait
autrefois et ce terme veut bien dire
quelque chose
aucun détail aucun mot aucun regard rien
n'est laissé au hasard fait un travail
coct ne fait plus de jeu alors louis
malle y at il eu pendant le tournage la
même irrésistible attraction entre les
acteurs qu entre les personnages écoutez
ça je crois que c'est vraiment une idée
un peu grossière c'est à dire l'idée que
le travail du metteur en scène c'est de
faire que ces acteurs tombent amoureux
l'un de l'autre et de les filmer faisant
au cinéma ce qu'ils font dans la vie
c'est c'est grossier c'est le contraire
de l'art si vous voulez moi je pense que
ce qui est important c'est de d'en
parler beaucoup avec eux de les préparer
je me suis trouvée avant le film répéter
certaines scènes nous étions tous les
trois juliette jérémy moi dans mon
bureau
c'était un peu bizarre alors il se
mettait par terre et puis ont commencé à
travailler les scènes mais la raison
pour laquelle je crois ses cinq sens
émouvante et est forte et ne sont pas
vulgaire c'est parce que c'est à cause
d'eux c'est parce que ils ont fait un
travail de professionnel pour moi est
extraordinaire et que on s'était bien
mis d'accord sur le fait que je leur
demanderai pas trop et quand même temps
à un moment donné je leur confier la
situation c'est donc eux qui ont fait
preuve si vous voulez de cette espèce de
l'intensité de violence de joie je vous
interromps le sens de la question
d'erick h arrêt était un peu ailleurs
été là comment vous avez fait vous pour
que ça monte s'étend sur ça qu'il
voulait dire
d'ailleurs est ce que ces personnages
après tout écrit sur papier
comment fait-on quand on est louis malle
pour et des gens qui se connaissaient
pas la veille en arrive là je crois
qu'il a voulu dire ça si vous voulez moi
je vais très longtemps que j'avais pas
tourner de
deux scènes d'amour et et au fond ça me
faisait peur parce que celle que je vois
en général au cinéma comme spectateur me
donne plutôt envie de fermer les yeux
parce que j'ai trouvé embarrassante
mais dès le départ j'avais on avait
parlé je leur avais dit des choses très
simples gens ravis par exemple dans ce
film vous ne vous embrasserait jamais
sur la bouche parce que c'est pas beau
et puis parce que c'est ce qu'on voit
toujours au cinéma
et puis on avait établi comme ça un
certain nombre de règles de ce qu'il
fallait faire et de ce qu'il fallait
essayer de faire les choses un peu
autrement je crois qu'il ya une
dimension dans leur amour disons dans la
sexualité par laquelle il s'exprime qui
est c'est pas du tout des gens qui se
donnent du plaisir la sorte de sa
cassette c'est qu'il ya il ya des
espoirs il ya aussi la la connaissance
que le la certitude que que c'est que
c'est quelque chose de tellement profond
que ça les dévore en même temps donc il
ya la mort qui est un peu présentes si
vous voulez louis malle henry chapier y
en eu l'amabilité de préciser le sens de
ma première question j'aurais quand même
imposer une dernière comment les
britanniques reçoivent style votre votre
regard plutôt critique sur leur société
je sais pas encore parce qu'il n'est pas
sorti en angleterre mais les premières
réactions qu'on a eue sur ta peu bizarre
parce que si vous voulez c'est quand
même un film ça film anglo français
m'ont fait il est tourné en angleterre
alors une réaction que j'ai eue pour
vous donner un exemple c'est quelqu'un
qui a vu le film qui a dit à settat des
meilleurs films anglais depuis très
longtemps et puis après un moment de
silence il a dit et puis d'ordures et
c'est pas du tout un film anglais alors
en fait je crois que c'est pas vraiment
un film anglais mais c'est quand même
aussi un film sur l'angleterre
merci louis malle fatale donc mercredi
sur vos écrans juliette binoche et
jeremy hunt